this morning Turkey's president is
accusing the u.s. of not living up to
its commitment to move Kurdish forces
out of northern Syria as president Trump
had promised US troops are still in that
region where the recent arrival of
Syrian troops backed by Russia is making
the area more dangerous Charlie d'Agata
has been covering this story extensively
from the region he's following a US
military unit near oil fields in
Northeast Syria for most of this morning
we've been falling around this US
military convoy as they've been visiting
oil facilities and oil fields in this
region in northern Syria they were
ordered to protect these oil fields by
President Trump so they don't fall into
the hands of Isis and their mission has
changed over the past couple of weeks
there's only a few weeks ago that
president Trump ordered US troops to
withdraw from this region and that
essentially gave the green light for
Turkey to invade and fight Syrian
Kurdish forces here hundreds of
thousands of people had to evacuate that
area hundreds of people have been killed
and there's a lot of criticism here now
the president Trump's order for these
troops to now secure oil fields suggest
that the US administration cares more
about protecting oil fields they do
about protecting civilians now as far as
the mission here is concerned US
military officials say their primary
operation has not changed and that is
the fight against Isis this part
securing the oil fields is simply part
of that mission Charlie d'Agata
reporting from northern Syria